WIL: Up first, the kill test.
Doug?
To see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
we'll deliver
slashes and thrusts
on this ballistics dummy.
Collin, you're up first.
You ready?
Have fun.
Let's do this.
To help me today, I'm
bringing back one of Marcaida
Kali's chief instructors.
Please welcome US Staff
Sergeant Chris Manns.
After the failure
in round two,
I'm hesitant to say that my
sword is going to be awesome.
I want to see what
my sword does.
And only then will I feel better
about my mistakes in round two.
[chuckles]
All right, Collin, your
Kabyle flyssa is very sharp.
On the initial thrust, it
penetrated deep and easily
through this whole
ballistics dummy.
The handle is comfortable.
It's easy to slash
in and thrust out.
Overall, it will kill.
Good job.
Thank you, sir.
All right, Daniel, your turn.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
I'm feeling a little
nervous about the kill test.
Win or lose, I just hope
my sword doesn't break.
All right, Daniel, your
weapon is wicked sharp.
On the initial thrust,
it penetrated deep.
And on the way out, with
your belly being forward,
it lacerates out easily.
Now, because you have such a
very skinny handle right here
and there is no pummel
with a counterweight,
all the weight is in front.
The balance just
makes the blade rotate
with a small handle like this.
But in terms of
damage it will kill.
Thank you.
DOUG: Good job.
All right, gentlemen,
now the sharpness test.
To test the sharpness
of that blade
and to see if it
still has an edge,
I'll be cutting
through these fish.
A clean, sharp blade should
pass right through those fish.
A dull blade is going to knock
those fish out of the way
or give us a jagged, torn cut.
Collin, you ready?
- Yes, sir.
OK.
And I'm just thinking, please
just slice through this thing.
All right, Collin, right off,
it's definitely a sharp blade.
It cut very nicely.
Your handle is a
bit on the fat side.
But it's definitely a cutter.
Good job.
Thank you, sir.
- Daniel, are you ready?
- Yes.
MAN: OK, great.
I feel that Collin and
I are still neck and neck.
I think that I've got
a good edge on him.
But all you can do is hope
for the best at this point.
All right, Daniel, this
blade is wicked sharp.
And those cuts-- you
can see, they just
blew right through the fish.
My problem is, this
is so small, I had
to fight to keep it in my hand.
These flyssa often have
a very small handle.
But what saves
that is having that
pummel keeping your
hand from coming
off the back of that blade.
It's an amazing cutter.
It's just very
difficult to hold onto.
WIL: Daniel, Collin, there can
only be one "Forged in Fire"
champion.
And that champion is Collin.
Congratulations, you are our
new "Forged in Fire" champion.